when you're fumbling um
every game obviously teams are gonna
lock in on it and they're gonna go for
it more and that just
uh is even more reason for me i need to
um i need to figure it out man
there's some good things that we can
take away but there's a lot of areas
that we need to improve and i think
it's one of those things where everybody
has to look at themselves i've got to be
better i've got to do a better job
out there and giving our guys chances
and
you know we'll look at this one and and
we'll move on from it
beauty the thing is uh
our division isn't doing that well this
year and now i mean we still got a shot
at it um
but uh we got we got to figure it out i
got to figure this thing out and i need
to be better this team
and lead them and go help them
win football games we've been playing
uphill every single game
you know we haven't we haven't gotten
into a groove or a rhythm and got out in
front
yet this year and it's it's the
self-inflicted wounds
that uh continue to plague us so
we got we got work to do and we gotta do
it fast
i don't think it really was much of what
they did uh
i think it was me um me i'm supposed to
be a guy this team
can rely on i'm supposed to be a guy
that this team can
can lean on when times get rough and and
i just wasn't that today
i gotta started off to a terrible start
defense were playing they were playing
well
but i killed our momentum two fumbles uh
i can't do that
i mean one i'm giving the ball away i
can't i wasn't helping the team and
i think they did the right thing and uh
you know gave
gave some of those reps to tp um but you
know i can't
i can't do that um i have to be a guy
uh this team can lean on you know
especially in the times
right now uh you know what so many of
our our starters hurting not playing um
so it's just it's not acceptable um and
i need to figure it out
i mean i started the game out with two
fumbles gave the ball away
and i gave them all the momentum that
they needed to go and
take off so i mean i was i want to say
i'm sorry this one's on me and i need to
be better for this team
ezekiel ellen after last night's 38-10
loss to the arizona cardinals fueled by
his two fumbles and chris look i i
somebody sent me an email overnight that
makes a ton of sense
and it's the perfect nudge i needed
because
someone needs to nudge ezekiel elliott
to go see a sports psychologist and i
don't
mean that in a joking way i don't mean
that in a sarcastic way or a pejorative
way
plenty of athletes see psychologists to
help them process these issues
he's got it in his head he's going to
fumble you can't be talking that way you
can't be thinking that way because you
know what's going to happen
you're going to fumble you're going to
continue to fumble
he needs to get in a mindset where he's
not worried about fumbling it's like
anything else in life the more you worry
about doing something you will yourself
into it
you unconsciously push yourself that way
yeah and you make yourself vulnerable
also
maybe he needs to consider how he's
holding the ball remember how tiki
barber yeah cured his fumbling problem
right the high and tight it looked goofy
but he stopped fumbling after that
so there's a lot of things the cowboys
need to do
and you know when you're bad and when
you're losing
it's an avalanche of issues that you
have to deal with somebody's got to get
ezekiel
elliott in a spot where he's getting the
advice he needs
he's talking it through he's processing
it so he not
he's not going to continue to fumble the
ball because the way he's talking i
guarantee you he's going to continue to
fumble
the ball unless there's some sort of
intervention that gets him thinking
differently and carrying the ball
differently yeah well how can it not be
in his head i mean
you're right so there's going to have to
be adjustments made i mean certainly and
this guy has never really had this type
of problem his whole career or
at ohio state or anything like that but
you know i think between
yeah whatever it is adjusting technique
mindset a little bit about how you carry
the football
and then just the natural human reaction
of
you know probably trying to do too much
you know really too you know the first
fumble
it's a little unfortunate i don't know
if it was necessarily careless andy
dalton's under pressure he kind of
shovels it out there
to ezekiel elliott and as he's like oh
wait i got the ball because he was just
in pass protection now he's thinking let
me go make a play he's
really in the process of tucking it away
buddha baker is a hell of a player comes
in and he's
all arms and swatting at the ball and it
was great but
the problem is they're paying ezekiel
elliot like he's the best running back
in football
and that hasn't been the case and their
defense
is crappy i mean it's as crappy as it
can get
and they just can't afford to make any
mistakes on the offensive side of the
ball
and unfortunately for them whether it's
dak prescott interceptions before the
injury or ezekiel elliott fumbles
they've really put them in some tough
spots in some of these games
and they just can't do that anymore
because dak prescott's not
out there you know that's one thing we
know andy dalton's good football player
one thing we know after last night is he
ain't zach dak prescott
dak prescott is a little bit better than
people want to give him credit for but
yeah the cowboys just can't make those
mistakes mike they're not a good
football team
well and you know what the point that
you've made from time to time that i
think becomes
critical right now when you consider the
injuries that offensive line is a shadow
of what it used to be right
and at one point last night they said
the guy with the most experience on the
line some guy that i can't even remember
what his name is a third year player
like
they have so many key players out along
their offensive line that offensive line
is so much worse than it was
and isn't that football that's the way
football's always been when your
offensive line is great
sometimes it's so good that people are
in awe of it but even then who gets the
praise yeah who gets the attention who
gets the notoriety
it's the quarterback it's the running
back it's the receivers
and and and i think that's the biggest
challenge for any professional football
team
understanding why your great running
back
is playing great is it him or is it
everyone around him right and that's the
tough decision when you allow yourself
to have a workhorse who puts up big
numbers
and everyone has his jersey and everyone
wants to talk to him and he's a
superstar
is it that he's an interchangeable part
yeah or is it that he's going to be a
star no matter what's going on around
him like a barry sanders and we're
seeing it and
this isn't a criticism of ezekiel this
is just reality without blockers
what can he do without dak prescott what
can he do
that's why it's a team sport but you
know
i'm i i suspect that the cowboys regret
paying zeke the contract they paid him
definitely they let demarco murray walk
away
trusting that hey we can find somebody
else to take his place because we've got
a great offensive line and they did
and and uh it's it's just unfortunate
because you get too much money
invested in one position and it's not
delivering when you don't have the
blocking there and i think that's one of
the big problems right now for the
cowboys offense
yeah definitely and it is uh you know
like you just said too
it's not going to change you know the
the cowboys offensive line
the days are over the glory days are
over they're older they're beat up
it's not the same group tyrone smith i
mean we know lyle collins
you know not there and then there is
zach martin you're going well they still
got zach martin
oh well he's in concussion protocol
during the game last night
so they're not going to be able to
continue to rely or be able to ride on
like this is 2014 or 2016 and we're
going to control the ball for 35 minutes
and
we're just going to run the ball and our
defense will only have to be on the
field for a little bit and then they'll
fly around and create chaos no
they're going to still have to go back
to that passing game that's what it's
going to have to be
and it's going to be tough too because
you know i just don't see how that
defense gets a whole lot better i mean
the way kyler murray ran around on them
and did some of those things last night
you know the cowboys are just not a good
football team
but they're not out of it because of the
nfc lease nobody's out of it
but the defense is abysmal not just bad
it's historically bad
it's right it's the the fourth most
points given up
in league history through this number of
games and and
they there's no reason to think they're
going to be any better and i still think
there's a chance mike nolan's going to
get fired at some point during the
season if not today
but you know what's starting to bubble
up now because for the past several
years
jerry jones and stephen jones have been
praised for putting together a team well
now the team stinks
they're being criticized again and and
look
when you don't have competent backups on
the offensive line
when your defense doesn't match the
scheme that you're trying to run and
you're the ones making the decisions on
who the coaches are going to be
that your head coach hires you're at
least involved and you got a spoon in
the stew
while these decisions are made it does
fall back on that it does
and and if they were in any other
division right now it would be a hundred
times worse but you're right they're two
and four they're in first place in the
worst division in football
and one of those teams two and four
cowboys one four and one eagles
one in five giants one in five
washington
one of those teams is going to host a
great number five seed whether it's
packers or bears out of the north
whether it's bucks or saints out of the
south
whether it's seahawks rams 49ers or
cardinals out of the west
there's going to be a great team that
has to go on the road and
play one of these crap franchises in the
postseason
and that's what's wrong about the
current configuration of the nfl
four teams per division is not enough
because you have years like this
and it's not like one out of ten it
seems like every year there's one
division
where we're like why is the champion of
that division
hosting a playoff game i know i well and
it's it's gonna be ugly this year
because you know the nfc east they're
playing
the nfc west and the afc north which are
you know the two best divisions we have
in football i believe i mean i think you
agree with that
and yeah they're not out of the woods
yet they're not i mean
they still got yeah of course the people
in their division but the ravens and the
steelers and the 49ers they're all still
waiting there for the dallas cowboys so
uh i i don't know but i think the the
thing you said the defense is really
the biggest biggest issue i mean they
hung in there a little bit
early on but that was only because kyla
murray was a little off throwing the
football
and like you know arizona just couldn't
kind of get their mojo going
but after they kind of got a feel for
the game and kyler started you know
feeling good about what he was doing
yeah i mean the game was over big plays
those fumbles everything like that
and it's just dallas can't stop the run
they don't have people that can cover
people on the outside
you can see they they got no great pass
rush the jones family
you know i think let the shelf life of
this team just go a little too long
that's probably where they miss
evaluated a little bit to where there
needed to be a little more more turnover
for a team that you know we we've had in
that
oh could this be the year for the dallas
cowboys for the last three or four
years we've kind of been saying that and
of course it's it's not going to be that
way this year
you could make the argument that dak
prescott made himself a hell of a lot
more money
tonight but but but again if you end up
making that gigantic financial
investment in dak
you better hope that you can go back to
six seven years ago and start hitting on
these draft picks again
because that's how you're going to
rebuild this team it's not going to be
through free agency
especially if you end up giving dak
prescott a huge percentage of your total
salary cap
you're going to have to find young guys
who come in with
relatively low pay in comparison to guys
like dak and zeke and who knows how much
longer zeke's going to be there under
the contract he signed
and you have to reload that way and and
there's that
that constant urgency with the cowboys
and i get it i understand that i'd be
the same way if i had just turned 78
and i'm desperate to get another super
bowl championship and it's all i'm
thinking about
and i want one that that came from the
team i built not the team that
jimmy johnson built it just i think it
takes on a life of its own and it
creates so much pressure and stress for
everyone in the organization
where there's this overwhelming let's
get one while jerry's still the owner of
the team
i think it almost curses them to not get
one while jerry's still the owner of the
team chris
yeah i mean i would think it certainly
you know puts pressure
on the situation uh but yeah they're
they're in a tough spot and and they're
gonna have to
get in the off season and they'll have
to figure out how to rebuild their
football team and where to go from there
but there's just
you know there's so many issues the
defensive line is so not talented and
then it doesn't match up with mike nolan
in the scheme he wants to run
and that's probably the biggest issue
overall you know you you brought it up
earlier in the conversation that that's
where i don't
quite understand where that got off
track in the off season
wait we're gonna hire a guy on defense
that wants to play you know a 3-4
type stuff on the defensive line he
wants defensive tackles who just
hold people up and read the play and
they got defensive tackles there that
don't do that and they never have and
there is really a
disconnect there and i don't understand
the thought process in the off season
to think that that might work or not
change over players at that position
or just not hire mike nolan altogether
and go wait this makes no sense
for this defensive personnel to play
with that coach
that's going to take a few years for
that to mold and work the right way
and we're seeing yeah it's not going to
work this year unless they get new
personnel or a new defensive coordinator
out there
and the other reality last point on this
it isn't something that we should be
figuring out and talking about during
the season this is part of the proper
setting of expectations going into a
season the cowboys should have been
talking about this well you know it's
going to take some time for this defense
to gel
because we have a different system than
we had and it's going to take some time
to get the right pieces
and if you admit that early going in
then you don't have this sense hey here
come the cowboys and the cowboys are
talented and they've got dak and they've
got zeke and they've got this and
they've got that and they have cd lamb
he fell into their laps
and you get this unwarranted sense of
excitement around a team
and then reality sets in and i think the
joneses are so caught up in seizing on
any and all excitement they can get real
or imagined
they just don't care they can't help
themselves yeah we get some hype we're
going to ride it we'll worry about
tomorrow later for now they're they
think we're going to be good
and you know what maybe we won't be good
but at least we had a few months where
people thought we were going to be good
the cardinals we thought they were great
and then they lost a couple of games
that they
should have won arguably and now they've
beaten a couple of teams that
grand scheme of things who knows how
good yeah the cardinals really are but
3810 is impressive here's kyler murray
who went back to texas last night and
got it done
it was fun it uh brought back a lot of
memories
felt like you know felt like i've been
playing there every sunday honestly
um it was comfortable felt good
you know it was uh started off sloppy i
mean for me personally the whole game
was sloppy but
you know we did we played a play
i feel like uh but you know besides me
um you know running backs around well
hole line played great our defense i
can't say enough about them
and what they did tonight you know
receivers made plays when they needed to
but we we still can be a lot better and
it starts with me
yeah nine for 24 at passing
but but still got it done he had 74
rushing yards he had a touchdown
he's just so elusive he's so excited
even when you only complete nine passes
it's fun to watch start to finish and
he's right about the defense
look i don't know that they would have
been able to win that game if the
defense wasn't as good as it was last
night
and that's been the the big question you
had about this team
where's their defense right and they
don't have chandler jones so there was
concern that maybe
you know they're not going to be very
good on defense they're going to have to
win shootouts and calamari is going to
have to play extremely well each and
every week but to win 38 to 10
when the stats are kind of yeah you know
he had three total touchdowns but the
yardage
and the passing it just to still have
that kind of a convincing win tells me
they're on to something chris well
it i mean they got some play makers and
there's some things that really like
about their football team i think like
in totality
i still feel kind of the same way about
them going into the game though i'm just
not quite sure
yet you know that we know that's not a
good cowboys football team who
served up a little like hey you guys
need to get going and play better here's
the ball two times for you early on to
get get jump started we want to be nice
guests here down in texas and
you know make you feel at home so here's
the ball zeke elliott very
nice man like that so but though i mean
uh
it's still moments though you see just
like with the passing numbers
where it's underwhelming and things
don't click and it seems like defenses
are all over them a little bit
you know the numbers are gonna look good
the yards are gonna look good
but it's a one play 80 yard touchdown
it's the big run at the end of the game
by kenyon drake that makes his stats
look good
i'm just not sure still if the offense
has enough to
offer to beat like the middle class and
above nfl type defenses that's what i
want to see
going forward you know kyla murray's
three weeks in a row
is a little off throwing the football
and you know i know i texted you last
night
i've noticed just this real quick
because i know we got to go to a break
soon but i've noticed his motion has
changed a little i wonder if he's got a
little arm
tendonitis i want somebody in arizona to
ask about arm 10 tonight is because he
has some of the
things he does he's changed his motion a
little bit to be
longer which makes me think maybe he's
got a little thing there
and mike i'm being total quarterback
looking into this but there was a few
times walking off the field last night
where he would unbuckle his chin strap
only with his left
arm and he would leave his right arm
hanging there i i just wonder that i
don't know why i brought that up because
i'm a quarterback i think he's
sorry i i think i think that's a fair
observation though when you see how
someone leaves the field and what
they're
favoring what they're protecting and
like that and i'm like wait wait your
right arm's there usually you just do
that or you go both of them and like
that's it and
just between the throws that we've seen
them miss the last few weeks and things
like that i just wonder
we're gonna find out a lot about the
cardinals in five days because they play
the seahawks
i don't know if that counts as a bingo
but they play the seahawks they play the
seahawks twice out of the next four
games
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports